investment into the fund that of the
russian entrepreneurs union
into the russian high tech and these
goes for the russian
manage venture management companies too
will have more
investment into technology the
participation of our partners
thus the russian direct investment fund
continues playing an important role in
the investment breakthrough
area in these self
generation cycle with us create jobs
start new projects and new companies to
conclude i would like to state that
investors confide in the russian economy
for example a dollar fund together with
us implemented 66
investments and today they see that
they've been printed trillions of
excess euro and dollars that
convert into inflation across the globe
that is why
they are increasingly confident in the
russian market and they stand ready to
invest into the russian economy given
the growth of the
market value of russian companies that
they are expecting as for the
coronavirus fight
we invested a lot into
tests and medicine and as for the
sputnik v vaccine there are three
important
points indeed the performance of the
vaccine
in hungary india mexico show
that our vaccine is the best in terms of
its efficacy and safety
besides we had clinical tests in india
uae and thanks to these results
we are the second vaccine in the world
in terms of the countries that
it has been registered into and even in
the countries
where there is disinformation campaigns
waged against buttoning
on a daily basis such as germany over 60
percent of germans stand ready to
have a sputnik v jab according to the
last
public survey besides we also launched
the sputnik light vaccine that showed
efficiency of over 60 percent
and two days ago argentina
prove that the efficacy of the vaccine
is over 80 percent
when it comes to the elderly
in argentina if you allow mr president
we would like to
start a short
footage on the production that we
started
upon your instructions and then we give
the flow to our colleagues from serbia
and argentina
on the production facilities in these
respective countries
is a vaccine for the entire human kind
sputnik we demonstrate
efficacy of over 97 according to
analysis of data of the mass vaccination
program in russia
the vaccine is affordable
is it a transport and store supported by
the russian direct
investment fund sputnik v has been
approved for use
in more than 65 countries with a total
population of over
3.2 billion people the
luxon is
to be approved in other countries of the
world
the president of the russian federation
proposed to
produce the vaccine in partnership
agreements on the vaccine production
have been reached with more than 20
countries and 13 countries in india
the partners to
produce are weaker group
panicker bill tech stelis pio farmer
glenn firma and buckhart
the rdf if partners in china
the manufacturers who are on biological
bacteria in the joint venture
top bridge former and jeans sale biotech
and shenzhen yongsan tech in south korea
it is gl
rolfer and isu abscess
in latin america those are unequal
kumiko
in brazil and laboratories richmond in
argentina
in the european union vaccine production
will be carried out in germany and they
are rf farm production site and in italy
by diana and davara
in serbia the boxing is produced by the
state institute tulluck in saudi arabia
the
partner
the vaccine is produced by synagogue
in turkey in iran by octoberko
and cinegen group in kazakhstan the
vaccine is produced by
kerriganda pharmaceutical complex and in
the republic of belarus
by belmatt preparati all our partners
join their efforts to win the fight
against coronavirus
the operation of these companies can
ensure a total manufacture of sputnik v
sufficient to vaccinate over 800 million
people per year
mr president all these partnerships have
been put together
at your request the
president of serbia will show the launch
of manufacturing of this vaccine in
serbia
good afternoon distinguished president
dear friend
dear friends
thanks to the support of president putin
and the work of the researchers
today we observe
the vaccine against the current virus
this technology was spread beyond russia
and the production of the vaccine will
be launched in serbia
president putin and the entire
russian people achievement
will be at the base of the
work of the toloc institute of the
republic of serbia
[Music]
the launch of the production is a
demonstration of
interaction between our countries all
the platforms observe the sincere
support
between our countries mr president it's
a great honor for me
to launch the production of russian
serbian
vaccine together with you
you've once mentioned that
sputnik is as efficient
as the kalashnikov rifle
i assure you tallock institute is as
efficient as kalashnikov rifle
russia helps us to create weapon against
coronavirus
we are launching the serial production
of
4 million doses of vaccine
production i would like to congratulate
your institution and our institution
institute with the production of this
vaccine
i'm honored to have this friendship with
your country
all the best to you and now i would like
to give the floor to the head
of turlock institution to launch the
production in serbia
virus turkovic
the president of the russian federation
dear president of serbia
ladies and gentlemen
serbia was one of the first countries in
europe that have started
to vaccinate its population
thanks to the use of the sputnik v
vaccine
and its high efficiency
that is 91.6 serbia has preserved the
health and lives of its citizens
[Music]
today serbia is one of the european
leaders
in the number of vaccinated citizens
over 30 percent of its population is
fully vaccinated which is
two times higher than the european
average
and the russian direct investment fund
is a
successful example of cooperation
between our two friendly countries in
times of the crisis
and the leadership of rdif
for their support they provo provide to
our institute and the republic of serbia
i would like to emphasize the role of
our
presidents mr and mr putin
thanks to them serbia is becoming the
first country
in europe that will produce sputnik v
in its territory
[Music]
let me press the button and launch
the production of sputnik v in serbia
[Applause]
[Music]
this
um
thank you so much now i would like to
give the flow to our
counterparts from argentina so that they
would
state that they launch the production in
argentina the floor is yours
president
i am
mr president thank you for the
invitation to participate in this forum
in st
petersburg
indeed argentina was the first
country in the latin america that has
registered sputnik v
and the second country in the world
yet it is not enough
we intend to use the vaccine produced by
camellia institute and that we start
to receive
russian science is
the basis that helped us
to achieve
the development of vaccination russia
has not only contributed to the
development
of energy resources but also in the
development of the vaccine that is of
utmost importance for our world
friendship with russia
is lasting for 136 years for this time
russia and
argentina has become strategic partners
it helps us to develop faster
than it could be possible without russia
interestingly the pandemic has opened
new opportunity for us
to get closer to russia and the russian
society
and to strengthen our relations
as never before
g20 summit and i said
that the world can get an access
to the vaccine that will serve as a new
impetus
for us and for other developing
countries
this will help us to develop our own
research and development capacities
this will not only be favorable for
the low income countries but for the
middle-income countries as well
and argentina is a middle-income country
let me stress that
we are glad to be a part of production
of this vaccine
[Music]
and i'm not alone in this view
get an opportunity a great opportunity
thanks to the achievements made by
russia russian research centers and rdif
all the more argentinians get an
opportunity
to get vaccinated
i'm very grateful for
argentina will say the threatened
friend in need is a friend indeed
russia's government the rdif
and gamalia institute help
us
and it is great that we have such
allies in the world
[Music]
we are glad that today will launch
subject matter efforts and we launch the
production
of sputnik v in argentina
hopefully
receive new requests
for the production of sputnik v for our
neighbors for instance
uruguay we've transferred your vaccine
to
bolivia
hopefully we'll provide the vaccine to
mexico and other latin american
countries
so that your vaccine would reach the
latin american continent i'm pretty sure
all these countries will be grateful for
so i would like to express my sincere
gratitude
and i say goodbye to you thank you for
all your efforts mr president
thank you i now would like to give the
floor to mr figueres
to launch the production of sputnik v
in argentina
good evening from argentina president
putin
when i started
i would like to thank you the russian
direct
investment fund and russia for this
opportunity
during this pandemic cooperation has
been key to successfully halting
the spread of koi 19 here
at laboratories richmond with a great
support
from the russian direct investment fund
we are eager to seize opportunity
that this agreement offers us to
turn argentina into a vaccine production
hub
for all of latin america as you know
the first vaccine available to
argentines
was sputnik b what's more
argentina was the first country in south
america
and i believe the second in the world to
register
sputnik b and start vaccinating its
population in december 2020
now less than six months after the first
vaccines
arrived from russia argentina is going
to be the first country in the region to
produce
sputnik b to the russian direct
direct investment fund and this
agreement that we are
celebrating today we've
received malaya's authorization and
laboratory
richmond is starting production we
expect capacity to total
100 million sputnik v doses per year
by the end of 2021
clearly sputnik this production in
argentina
will greatly boost local industry
as well as argentina's scientific and
technological development
it is the outcome of serious scientific
work
from dedicated specialists who are
paving the way for argentina to have
long-term installed production capacity
and in our state-of-the-art plant
currently under construction that will
be the most
modern of its kind in latin america in
latin america
we will reach a capacity to total 500
million doses per year
i hope to have president fernandez
present for the inauguration
and i hope that you president putin will
be able to visit
one day none of this would have been
possible without the support
and the commitment of the argentine
government
and the russian direct investment fund
and we are proud to help play a role
in fighting the pandemic i would like to
close
with a small gesture that means a lot
i would like to invite you and everyone
present
to witness the official kickoff of
spockney v production in argentina
now president putin and president
alberto
i would like you to authorize the
official launch of the production
process
of spoonie b in argentina
oh
thank you mr figueras it is indeed a
very
important indicator this is the first
production capacity that has been
launched in argentina
in south america we'd like to thank our
colleagues
from serbia and argentina first i would
like to give the floor
to our colleagues from india mr reddy
uh chief of board hetero please the
floor is yours sir
okay thank you his excellency vladimir
putin
honourable president of asia mr kirill
dimitri
urdf all dignitaries across the globe
a very good evening to all it's a moment
of great pride and privilege for me
to be representing our organization
petrol and being a part of this
interactive section
with president putin hetero is one of
the leading indian multinational pharma
companies
engaged in developing manufacturing and
supply of global generics
and complex bias similars across
therapies
rooted in the philosophy of bringing
affordable measures within the range of
all
we are enabling access to a range of
life-saving drugs
at economical costs to over 120
countries
not to mention we cater to about 40
percent of the global demand of
hiv drugs we have established a state of
the art formulation facility
market in moscow by investing 50 million
u.s dollars
a decade back thanks to russia's
encouraging business environment
and time to time support from government
officials we continue to make
healthy progress
the highlight of our 27 years of
existence has been
our responsive actions to mitigate
pandemic and life-threatening diseases
reflecting communities around the world
since the onset of the ongoing kovite 19
pandemic
we have been proactive in forging global
collaborations to bring
potential therapies to save lives it is
in this
inherent spirit to contribute to the
world we partnered with
rdif for production of sputnik v version
in india
for meeting domestic and global
requirements
jointly with rdf we have successfully
concluded
technology transfer r d trials and
started commercial production
in a world class facility where the
vaccine is ensured
to meet highest quality standards we are
very
thankful to rdif for its instrumental
role
in helping us to start the commercial
production of sputnik
gas in india further hetero is committed
to invest in scaling up our capabilities
for
delivering 200 million of sputnik v on
sputnik light
on this occasion we assure mr president
that we are committed to make this
project successful
we are very grateful to president putin
for seeding the idea of
russian indian partnership which has led
to this game-changing development
our honorable prime minister of india
sri narendra modi in his recent meeting
with all indian vaccine manufacturers
acknowledges the russia's support in
sharing sputnik we with india
in the light of the devastating second
wave i believe sputnik v becomes
vital to boost our nation's vaccination
program
i am extremely honored to have had this
opportunity
thank you one and all
[Music]
do
good morning or good afternoon dear
friends
time to start there is some
administrative hiccup with
online communication but let us start
and then the technicians will
attend to it
why should we get together we know all
the things
but there are some outstanding issues
first we'll have to
think about the future whether we are to
expect
new waves of new pandemics and then we
will have to talk about the lessons
learned of
what is happening michael you are the
first one i know
you have a presentation but as a
journalist they cannot
but do without the news and
we have we have read a lot about the
origins
of the papyrus and one of the theories
that it is
aliens then institute
vi
where did it come from though there is a
debate
on the origin
and when there will be a final version
well substantiated we will present it
as now i don't think it is correct to
talk about
the origins one more than one year
have passed no matter what it has
come from but the prospects are still
frightening
and we cannot see
any single political willpower
to counter it we see
propaganda counter propaganda instead of
fighting it or countering it jointly
what do you think about the results of
this year
and what will the future
bring us why did russia
had one called this and the others
uh countries had more
why there are corvid dissidents
present what's the status at the present
at present we have not
finished the work against pandemic there
are
still sites with the higher rate of
infections we are moving in the
right direction true but the velocity
depends
on each and every one of us it is the
situation when we should think about the
collective safety and vaccination
is one of the ways to
cope with this situation to cooperate
things in the world
w-h-o is very active
there was a world assembly of the health
care
industry and
dr tedros made a proposals
proposal to develop new
regulations on consolidation
of the efforts to counter
new challenger challenges and
the they say on the face of it
that there is a cooperation of the
health care
organizations on the other hand they
say that there should be
a more consolidated approach and the
response for for spreading
and it is related to the
resources to the access to the resources
production and the financial and uh
there is
a framework one is
to supply vaccines
to the countries that that do not
produce it or buy it
and the food supply also on the increase
and another
component is scientific
study continuation we should continue
with
it and looking for both ways of
treatment and prophylactics
prevention this these efforts
should not be stopped we should not idle
about
it what are we to
expect saying that it is only a first
harbinger i am not talking about
the kovid but about the
new infections
for the past 10 or 15 years
we have been facing new challenges
it is h1 and 1
and the other species of the family of
coronavirus of course we will have to
face the infection
challenges and the it's the wake up
call and we should respond
quicker new approaches to monitor
the beds of infections to localize them
and neutralize them and we should also
develop a test system medicinal drugs
and vaccines as well and the president
and his address referred to the
necessity to
reduce the timeline for
both components it is uh for also
for the testing and for the development
of the vaccines and there is
a catch word saying that
vaccine is the arms the weapon that is
used after the combat is over
that's that and it was always like that
when the pandemic was over the vaccines
have been developed but the situation is
different now
vaccines are being developed in
the course of the pandemic and
it is being used during the pandemic
it is a new innovative approach and
we hear the word digitization i have
a number of slides we can have a look at
them
so what is the meaning of the
digitization it is it refers
to how many threads and parallels we
have been facing
here are some of them that occurred
in the past 2
000 years and
if we look at the pandemic management
things and how we work against it
the experience is unique
there are frameworks to detect new
viruses
maybe not that contagious but still
here is a map of the
country and it shows how the infection
spread
it is based on the real data road
primary data
and it shows the growth
rate the increase in the number
of the infected people and
you can see that there there is a
running
date line and
you can zoom to a specific
settlement and town city
and it's a new understanding
on how to control
to manage the process and
the the map has got the information on
the
number of the vaccinated you can
you can have both a direct flow of time
and
reverse it and on the face of it the
picture is simple
nothing complicated for it to
develop it but you will have to make it
part of your daily life
and that's what i meant to to
demonstrate in
my powerpoint presentation
and i had an interview with
the director general w.h.o
mr correction
uh u.n secretary general mr
yaresh and he said that there are some
countries that haven't been
vaccinated and
the coronavirus
infection rate could